اما زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يائير
لابيت فقال ان المعارضه ستمنح الحكومه
شبكه امان لكل صفقه تبادل اسرى يتم التوصل
اليها هذا ويعقد المجلس الوزاري
الاسرائيلي المصغر للشؤون الامنيه
والسياسيه جلسه بعد غد الخميس لبحث مقترح
صفقه لتبادل الاسرى وكان مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي قد عقد جلسه لمناقشه تفاصيل
الصفقه بعد عوده رئيس الم من اجتماع باريس
وافادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بانه الان
في انتظار الرد الرسمي لحركه حماس على
الصفقه ينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراس
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس نتابع معك
المواقف الاسرائيليه فيما يتعلق بما جرى
في
باريس نعم بالفعل فدى ولعل الاهم في كل
هذه التصريحات هي تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو ولماذا هي الاهم هي الاهم
لان بنيامين نتنياهو يريد ان يقول انا هو
اليمين الحقيقي وهو يوجه كلامه هذا الى
تمار بن كفير والى بيتسل ايس مترش الذين
يحاولان ان يقولا بانهما هم اليمين
الحقيقي في في اسرائيل وبالتالي بنيامين
نتنياهو يحاول ان يحافظ على هذه التوليفه
اليمينيه المتطرفه لانه يدرك في نهايه
المطاف بانه مع انتهاء الحرب فان الوزير
بيني جان سوف يغادر حكومه الطوارئ وهو
يريد ان يثبت حكومته الحاليه التي تستند
على
4 صوتا في الكنيست من اصل 120 اي اغلبيه
تكاد تكون ضيقه وهو بالتالي يعرف بان
اليمين المتطرف وشركائه الذين يشكلون اساس
هذه الحكومه هم ربما يكونوا الاوفى له
ولهذه التوليفه لذلك يقول لهم تريثوا لن
نقدم كثيرا من التنازلات وهو هو يقول بان
اسرائيل لن تنسحب ولن تسحب جنودها ولن
تنهي الحرب حتى تحقيق هذا الانتصار المطلق
لكن من ناحيه اخرى نحن نرى ان اي زعيم
المعارضه يائير لابيد قدم مبادره علنيه
اليوم وقال وكانه يقول لبنيامين نتنياهو
تخلى عن الجناح المتطرف في الحكومه اي
تخلى عن بنفير وعن سموتريتش ونحن نمنحك
شبكه الامان ليس فقط بالضروره فدى
الانضمام الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه كشريك
في حكومه الطوارئ لكن يمكن
للقيد ولاعضاء حزبه ان يمنحوا شبكه الامان
للحكومه الاسرائيليه من داخل الكنيست
بمعنى عدم التصويت على حجب الثقه عن
الحكومه واطاله عمرها فيما اذا قدمت
الحكومه صفقه كما يقول لبيت تستعيد
بموجبها اسرائيل كل الاسرى المحتجزين في
داخل قطاع غزه وهذا امر في غايه الاهميه
حقيقه وهو يعلنه لاول مره على الملا بهذه
القوه ويؤكد عليه ان المعارضه الاسرائيليه
مستعده ان توفر هذا الدعم السياسي
لبنيامين نتنياهو اذا ما كانت هنالك صفقه
يمكن ان تؤدي الى استعاده الاسر فيده شكرا
لك الياس كرام مراس جزيره كنت معنا من تل
ابيب